hi gertie means my name is Ragini and
I'm the director of this episode of
spectrum we're very excited to be
partnering with AARP again especially
during the special month of May which is
also the Asian Pacific American Heritage
Month we're celebrating this month-long
celebration with AARP the nation's
largest nonprofit organization working
to improve the lives of 50-plus and
their families we absolutely love AARP
and their mission to empower people to
choose how they live as they age in fact
we previously partnered with them for
another episode of spectrum to all Asian
American para stayed the same so if we
haven't seen that make sure to check it
out
but for now enjoyed this episode hi
everyone my name is Michelle I'm
studying chemical engineering right now
I'm a Cambodian American woman my name
is Julie I was born in Korea and I've
been in the States ever since I was four
I teach Asian American Studies at Cal
State Long Beach my name is Asia I was
born in Pakistan and I run a used car
dealership my name is Mariana I was born
in Bangladesh and I currently work as an
associate at a financial services firm
my name is Luke kuma I am an
undergraduate student and I am Tibetan
American my name is Lillian I'm going to
be graduating with my undergrad in
neuroscience pre-medicine my ethnicity
is mom American I am expected to be
docile 3 2 1 go yeah I think people look
at me and expect me to have soft
opinions in my kind of assertion I can
tell that they did expect me to play
into that stereotype and they're
surprised that I didn't and then they
quickly then shift from okay she's not a
lotus flower she's a dragon lady got it
yeah I actually had the same experience
being kind of viewed as a weak character
and that consequently made me more
hot-headed because I felt like I had to
prove the opposite so in middle school
like late middle school early high
school I was really rowdy and I would
you know like argue with people all the
time but I'm fortunate
that within my own family especially
with my father he really stood up for me
I remember one time when I was sitting
at the dinner table and we had guests
over for dinner and one older man was
like okay like you're dismissed you can
go now and my dog was like no I want her
to stay like we're having a conversation
and he let me kind of contribute and
debate with them and I think that's
always been a really important
experience for me my cousin in Pakistan
she is the perfect know style woman and
she is very quiet and sweet and it
almost sounds like she's whispering all
the time in every one of my family
praises her and says that she's the
perfect girl I would sit with my legs
far apart on purpose just to like piss
off family members because I hated to
being told to be soft-spoken and bring
out the chai and serve and be submissive
for my experience I think I've kind of
like played into it a little bit but
like in the home rather or like with
people of authority and I think a lot of
the way I act is like in striving for
acceptance but like in society like I'm
kind of I like put on my other hat and
kind of headstrong I don't want to
conform to whatever you're putting me in
but then for my family like I want you
to love me so I'm going to like be that
daughter for you I want to be a tiger
mom three two one go I was very
fortunate to have a mom who was very
lenient and respectful and I think that
actually allowed for me to to kind of
like open up more and actually explore
things that I liked and didn't like and
naturally could allowed me to create
boundaries for myself I think that
there's kind of like degrees to the
tiger mom with my mom personally when I
was younger growing up I remember her
being pretty strict which I've grown to
appreciate now that I'm older once I
start to be able to form my own opinions
and be more mature she became more
lenient and kind of like a friend
I think Tiger mom's kind of get a
I also think there's a lot of
misunderstanding around them
I think Tiger moms come from this kind
of like Asian collective idea that our
lives are all linked together right so
if you fail we all fail personally I was
like a latchkey kid so my parents were
always working so I didn't have people
telling me like you need to do your
homework you shouldn't be meeting these
kids I had to learn that all on my own
and then eventually I was like a high
school dropout so I think Tiger moms
like their biggest strength is present
there's there I actually completely
agree with that
and my parents were definitely type of
parents that's what I grew up with you
know there there is undue pressure on
the child I still feel that today
because I live with my parents that
being said I do appreciate it I feel
like I am the person that I am and I
like Who I am
because of them yeah I have felt
pressure to marry at a certain age three
two one go two years ago my mom was
driving me back up to college and like
helping me move in that year and for
like maybe ten minutes away from campus
and she goes Lilian have you found any
nice like Hmong boys day at school and I
was like no mom I haven't found any
she's like oh what about any good
Christian boys most like no I haven't
found any of those either and she's like
uh you know why it's because you're so
bossy you're so impatient yada yada yada
like these are the reasons why you're
still single
and like you need to be a good like
feeling you need to prepare yourself to
become a good future wife and she just
continued this conversation about like
how she didn't want to be the mom back
at like back at home at her at a trade
show but then I families in our
communities to be like yeah my
daughter's the last one out of everyone
to get married how old are you again
Lilian so it's just two years ago so I
was 20 oh my god you have so much time
you're still so young it's okay my
family marriage is a very big thing and
it also comes from just cultural aspects
but also because my parents are most
lemon I live in a Muslim
family and so when I was younger they
stressed education and they stressed
like doing well and all of these other
things but outside of that like the
entire Bengali community would come up
to me they're like oh but don't work too
hard because you have to be marketable
for marriage or things like that and my
parents would never say that but there
was also the lingering thought that like
at 21 that I would arrange marriage
Asian women growing up for me were pure
innocent virgins and I never had a
boyfriend in high school never kissed a
boy so I was very impressed in that way
so when I was 18 I eloped and got
married and I blame a lot of that on my
hormones because I just couldn't wait
any longer and the only way for me to
get it was to get married and I look
back and I think did I married too young
I chose well because we're still married
today it's just those pressures of being
an Asian woman where if I was allowed to
be myself then I don't think I would
have gotten married that young we would
have waited my mom married my dad at a
very young age growing up they've really
instilled values of establishing
yourself first like getting an education
making sure that you go after what you
want in life and in fact like they
actually want me to delay it they're
like don't even think about boys yet you
know you want to be a successful
engineer go get your job and go you know
like establish yourself in a
professional sense and personal
well-being
my parents expect me to be that primary
caregiver
three two one go I think my parents
expectations versus what's gonna happen
is a little different they always tell
me you know once you're married and you
have a family they are your priority you
can't be taking care of us but I I
already know that there is still this
unstated expectation there's more
universal
taken beyond my parents for me to take
care of my parents financially
physically when the time comes but I
think my parents as individuals they
don't they don't expect that from me
my parents have shared that with me too
that like when I get made I'm you know I
shouldn't be worrying about them but
I've been a new family now and I think
my answer to this question would be
entirely different mm man because what
the Hmong culture it's that when you get
married you leave your family and you
join your husband side of the family I
see that with my older sister who
recently got married you know my mom so
it's just pushing her to like do things
for her new family but that's not going
to be the case right because you know
obviously when a girl gets married she
doesn't forego her old family it's tough
family well my parents peak English but
they have slight accents and they don't
understand when somebody's being
sarcastic with them or there's like a
racial microaggression growing up I used
to read important documents for my
parents and try to turn them just so
that they don't get in trouble with the
government and so I feel this need to
almost protect them also do you think I
sell cars because I like cars no my dad
started the family business just seeing
them so vulnerable in this country I
just took it upon myself I did it
because I wanted to be a good daughter
on both sides of my family on my mom's
and my dad's side all of the children
are very much involved in taking care of
the aging parents lives it's really
about just collectively coming together
and taking care of someone who dedicated
their whole lives to taking care of you
and just getting back but with my
parents at least they don't want me to
take care of them their only rule is
that I don't put them in a nursing home
they said if anything find a really good
caretaker but just like don't kick us
you know away and forget about us or
like mistreat us I am comfortable
talking about my mental and emotional
health with my family members three two
one go
hell no I never feel like I have the
right to be sad or upset I I remember
telling my dad for the first time that I
was depressed and he just looked at me
and laughed it's like what do you have
to be depressed about and it's hard to
explain to a man who literally started
working when he was 12 years old a man
who had to say goodbye to his mom and
dad and immigrated to this country and
then like a few months later they died
so it's like I I just like sweep it
under the rug I think that there is such
a stigma associated with mental health
and and that's why it's so difficult in
my family to talk about it because I
think in for Bengalis in general mental
illness equates to crazy like just being
crazy and like for my parents it's like
you're either crazy or you're not right
but I remember the first time that I
really realized that I was depressed it
was when I was in college and I attended
Columbia and I remember just being very
upset and I couldn't tell that to my
parents but I just told them like you
know I really didn't want to feel this
way or go to the school and I remember
my mom saying well at least you got to
go and I was like oh well now I can't
feel bad because like you never had that
opportunity so like I think a lot of
mental illness a lot of what we feel now
is very different from our parents
experiences and so they can't
necessarily like relate to it my story's
a little different because I actually
had depression when I was seven and so I
was a little kid and I was lucky enough
to have parents who took me to a clinic
to get help I know within the Hmong
community we are very spiritual people
so if you do have a mental health
illness oh it's not like other factors
it's like your spirit
it's your soul something's wrong with
your soul um you both talked about
having guilts like knowing that your
parents went through so much and you
know you're here living like a life
better than naked but you're still
feeling down you still feeling depressed
you still have anxiety and I think a big
thing of that is like generational
there's such thing as like Gen
irrational depression mental health it
impacts you all that I completely agree
with you about the kind of the cultural
gap and the generational gap I think
also in my parents language they just
grew up not even hearing about such a
thing as mental health I can talk to my
family if I'm not feeling well I can
talk about the problem but I think I do
not directly use words like I don't feel
mentally well or I feel depressed
because I think there is such a stigma
attached to those words in the larger
Asian community and in my community I
feel at home in America 3 2 1 go it's
kind of funny how like Asian people like
can be used as kind of a prop to further
like people's agendas like we can be
seen as a model minority and like ok why
aren't other ethnicities or racial
groups you know like performing as well
as then but now it's like ok we're kind
of cast in a light where we're like the
reason for you know this current issue
that we're all facing globally like it's
your fault and that's why a lot of
people are being like physically like
attacked it feels a little isolating
there's like not many people who are
allies for us but they're just like okay
yeah don't target people because they're
Asian but like I still feel at home
because I grew up here I live here and
this is home for me I actually feel very
differently so I was born and raised in
the US lived there for 20 years and just
now in August this past August moved to
Tokyo I feel much more at home in Asia
actually than I do in America I think
it's just been all my experiences kind
of accumulated going up and I don't
really miss America much surprisingly
and that really surprised me because
that's where I grew up it's my
native language to my native home always
raised both here in the United States
and in South Asia and I've never felt a
hundred percent like when I'm in
Pakistan I'm the middie gun then when
I'm here on the Pakistani and so neither
place has treated me I was like I'm a
hundred percent I belong there and
that's my home and I've come to terms I
you know it's never gonna be like that
but it's okay this entire time that I've
been here like South Asians Muslim
Americans we have been ostracized and
now I'm saying there is this shift it's
going to East Asians and my heart goes
out to you guys but it might never
really go away once you get that hey it
kind of stays with your community I was
actually just going to say that I mean I
am NOT personally affected like I'm not
part of one of that groups that's been
harmed or targeted because of Koba 19
but speaking to 9/11 and the backlash
from that I don't see that going away
and I feel like this may not go away
either
and it's unfortunate that minorities
aren't allies always and they should be
because in times like these we need
people to speak up for us when we don't
have a voice or feel threatened I think
right now we kind of have this
flourishing of Asian American
storytelling right
there's affirmative action which by the
way absolutely benefits asian-americans
too so we see asian-americans in these
different spaces that we hadn't seen
them before but I think the Yellow Peril
idea never really went away that it is
what Asian Americans still are and it's
just we can put as much paint over it as
we want but all it takes is one virus
and then that comes right back up you
know a lot of Asian Americans are like
we need other people to stand up with us
we need other people of color to condemn
this but I'm like we didn't really step
up for these other people either
I can't expect we can't expect other
people of color to care when they
remember when they were going through
something similar and we were like sorry
I'm the model
minority I can help you you know I just
I think there's such a trauma within
each of our groups and we don't realize
that we'd be so much stronger if we
could just see how similar we are and
also despite 9/11 30s and why I selected
agree it's because I still feel like I'm
entitled to share the same spaces of
other people so I still consider it the
u.s. my home I feel like I belong here
and no one could really take that away
from me even if they try I wish I could
give you all a hug right now it's really
nice to know that other people like
share similar experiences and to like
learn about your backgrounds as well
yeah this has been really enlightening
just talking to people from all over
with a lot of different backgrounds so
thank you for achieving such a diverse
cohort it's been really nice thanks
again to BRP for sponsoring this episode
of spectrum for over sixty years
AARP has been serving its people and
their communities they're also educating
about frauds and scam and giving tips on
how to lessen the stress and anxiety to
wreck this time
AARP also offers resources and tools to
help us as we age like tips on how to
make home safer for people to age in
place and even a free online caregiving
guide that can help us begin to prepare
to care for our loved ones after all all
of us will either be a caregiver or need
care and during this time of social
distancing AARP has been giving tips and
resources to help families and loved
ones to connect socially and avoid
social isolation for more information on
the many ways in which AARP serving its
community please visit the website erp
dot org slash caregiving thank you for
watching this episode and I'll see you
next time and I think it feels really
nice to be back on set
different